this is one of the problems with this  left-wing gender ideology is that no one  who espouses it can even tell you what  these words means like what is a woman  can you tell me what a woman is  no i can't  because it's not for me to say  womanhood looks different for everybody  do you what do you define a woman as an  adult human female and what does a  female mean how do you define it someone  with with female reproductive organs  here's the thing when you're when you're  female it goes right down to your bones  your dna so that's why if someone  dies okay we could dig up their bones a  hundred years from now we have no idea  what they believed in their head but we  can tell what sex they were because it's  in it's down in it's it's ingrained in  every fiber of their being